[Music]
it's a monday pft ot the extra show
where we talk about things we didn't get
to during pft live or things that we
just want to talk about some more and
who doesn't want to talk about the
antonio brown situation chris sims but
what we're going to do now instead of
talking about what's happened let's get
very concrete and specific about what
happens next
grievance arbitrator making a decision
on whether or not antonio brown will be
required to wear a helmet other than the
one that he's worn for the last 10
seasons
what will that decision be i can't
expect it being anything other than
brown has to wear one of the approved
helmets so then chris the question is
does he comply does he submit or does he
try to find some other way
to get his way this is a guy who always
gets his way and i feel like he's not
going to go quietly on this one it's a
matter of ego it's a matter of pride
it's a matter of winning and losing i
can't help but wonder whether he's going
to try to come up with some other way to
go to court to do something to appeal to
the commissioner personally to get
permission to wear that helmet well i
don't think it's the end of this i'll
say that much now i you know again i
mean we know this guy you know can can
dance with you know craziness at times
and he's certainly dancing with it right
now we've never seen anything like this
uh but i don't think he's crazy enough
to leave 30 million dollars guaranteed
on the on the table and and walk away
from that so i do think he comes to his
senses now the question is yeah does he
let this does he continue to let it
fester i mean does he wear the helmet
during like interviews at his locker
room and things like that just to like
annoy people or or show that he's still
not happy about it uh i wouldn't be
shocked if he pulled some sort of antics
like that or something like that but
either way i really think when he does
get the final word here he's going to be
welcomed back to the oakland raiders
with open arms and that then will start
the building up of antonio brown through
john gruden's eyes and his you know
and the way he can do that to the team
and everything and endearing him back
with the football team and everything
like that and getting him back
indoctrinated with the offense and and
their their organization to where they
can start feeling positive again but uh
i would think that's coming this week to
where at least he's back out there
playing ball as long as his feet feet
allow him to
you know and we've referred kind of
tongue-in-cheek to antonio brown as
crazy throughout the day and i don't
mean to make light of mental illness and
and it could be it could be there is
something wrong with his wiring that
needs to be addressed right it could be
that he's not making rational decisions
and the people close to him if he won't
listen to reason need to suggest that
antonio brown get some sort of help
there's nothing wrong with that that is
a common problem in today's society
especially for a guy who has played
football at a high level and has taken
some blows to the head it is
it it may be that he's not capable of
processing things the way that he should
and i think that's where the the people
close to him family and agents and
lawyers need to say hey b are you
do we do you know
are you really you're going to retire
from football over this do you really
understand what that means do we really
you know do we need some to talk to
somebody else to help you understand
this because i don't see a guy who is
going to back down
and and i think he needs some if he
can't have sense talked to him someone
needs to recognize that maybe there's
something more going on here and i don't
want anyone to think that we're you know
because he could it could be that there
is something wrong with antonio brown
that needs to be addressed that he's not
making rational decisions because there
is nothing that seems rational about any
of this unless it really is driven by
ego and vanity and and just a desire to
get his way yeah i want my way i've
always gotten my way
and and we're going to find out once
that once that arbitrator makes a
decision
if antonio brown shows up in a new
helmet everything's fine but i have
there's no way it's going to go that
easily this is not this this isn't like
you know they make a decision on whether
or not there was a penalty in the game
just keeps going i have a feeling it's
going to be strange unusual and dramatic
before antonio brown is ever on a field
yeah my god i mean i i i think there'll
be something dramatic too um i think to
what you're saying too with antonio
brown you know i i don't think he's
legitimately crazy i don't think that
i'm saying that and the fact that i
think this whole scenario is crazy i
mean if he's crazy he's one hell smart
crazy guy with the way he got himself
out of pittsburgh he's the craziest damn
schemer smart guy i've ever seen okay um
where i do worry about antonio brown
though and we're just like we're just to
worry about antonio brown right this is
where he's hurting himself it's not
right now and it's not with the oakland
raiders but you know two years from now
if the oakland raiders decide okay you
know hey we paid him enough money he's
not worth the price anymore or whatever
we're going to move on the antics he's
pulling right now are really going to
affect his next contract or his next
football team to where it's not going to
give him the benefit of the doubt with
the other 31 teams in the nfl or 30
teams because we can cancel the steelers
and the raiders out of that conversation
and that's what he's got to worry about
if he was looking for one little other
small payday when this was all said and
done in oakland
he's not helping himself with this stuff
right now
this is a time when the nfl seems to be
looking for ways to allow great players
to play whether it's being
more lenient than they've been under the
substance abuse policy
more lenient than they've been under the
personal conduct policy not trying to
fashion reasons to keep great players
off the field but i think they reach
their limit with a guy like antonio
brown because the nfl does not like to
start making exceptions for anyone it is
ultimately our way and this is very
simple if they're going to freeze out
colin kaepernick
on very questionable and improper
grounds they're not going to hesitate to
tell antonio brown leave if you don't
want to play leave there are plenty of
other people who will play you are being
irrational you are being selfish you are
being delusional and ultimately the
choices are simple show up and he and
chris i can't say this enough he doesn't
have to play well to get 30 million
dollars over the next two years he
doesn't even have to make the team let's
say he shows up in a new helmet and he
just can't play football anymore it's
like samson getting his haircut by
delilah he's done he still gets 30
million dollars over the next two years
that's what that's why the idea that he
would not play football anymore is so
ridiculous but the problem is when pride
takes over and your ego writes that
check
sometimes guys do pretty stupid things
and they say i don't need any more money
i've made my money it's 30 million
dollars that you make for just showing
up and working that's what's going to be
fascinating to me will he show up what
else will he do will he try to go to
court will he try to go here will they
try to go what will he do we try to
appeal the president who knows what this
guy will try to do but it it's
definitely entertaining there will be
more drama and we'll see how it plays
out we'll be updating it all week long
at profootballtalk.com pft live chris
sims unbutton you'll hear about it
everywhere on every platform that we
have all right
something that we haven't heard about as
much as i thought we would through week
one of the preseason the replay review
procedures for pass interference only 14
red flags thrown in the 16 games played
between thursday and saturday night
chris we need to have these flags thrown
more off and we need to have more reps
for this system i know it slows down the
preseason games but we all need to get
an idea of what it's going to be like
the coaches need to know the fans need
to know the media needs to know how
riverrun needs the reps the the replay
officials in the stadium and the referee
going over talking to al river on well
all of that stuff it needs to be worked
on now so they can spot any problems fix
them or if nothing else just be ready to
go when that first game of the season
rolls around in only three weeks and
three days i i'm surprised it was what
16 is that what we said it was the
amount of challenges from this past week
i mean i'm i am surprised with that
number i thought it would probably be
more than that i'm not going to lie uh i
hear what you're saying i mean i don't
want it i don't want to see it because i
don't want it to slow down and bog the
games down even in the preseason hey the
preseason games they're not the most
exciting things to watch on all the
television history anyways so to have
that aspect of it can be a little
annoying but i understand your point and
the more that the these plays are
challenged the more we can flush out
these unintended consequences like the
play we talked about during the show
today which was of course that that
kansas city chief cincinnati bengals oh
challenge to see if it was offensive
past interference looked like it was to
me it wasn't called they left it on the
field as an incomplete pass and you
brought up all the right questions too
you know what's the result of the play
is that affecting the review and what's
ultimately being decided within the
review there i worry about that because
that did look like opi and i just i
would love to continue to hear the
dialogue and and i i i hope at some
point during this week we hear al
riveron explain that play thoroughly to
us so we can get a better feel of how
they are officiating it and what he saw
uh so we're not kind of in the dark
about some of these situations
yeah and there needs to be transparency
but there also needs to be a recognition
of how human nature will factor into
this and i am firmly convinced that
non-call of offensive pass interference
was driven by the fact that the ball
wasn't caught by the receiver and uh as
you pointed out it could have been
intercepted but for the past
interference if the if the penalty
happens it needs to be called and i will
say this the one time
that that i think it worked exactly the
way it should by way of reversing ruling
on the field it came earlier in that
same game chiefs bengals earlier in that
same two-minute window where the replay
official has the authority to activate
replay review byron pringle was hit
early blown up
before the ball got there and it was
obvious the defensive back dove into him
the ball came in flag thrown past
interference that's what the rule is
there to fix not well maybe he grabbed
his wrist maybe he still could have
caught it the situation where the guy
gets wiped out and the ball shows up
later that is the perfect opportunity to
overturn a non-call of pass interference
and i applaud that one i still don't
like the one from thursday night chris
with the jets and the giants i still
think it's not the high bar that it
needs to be at the moment you see it
full speed okay it's interference if you
should have to watch it two or three or
four times it's not clear enough to
overturn but the one you're on that
field you can't be mad at that just
because you don't get it from your tv
angle there was obviously 90 people on
the sideline including a head coach you
saw it and they wanted it thrown so you
know once you saw the replay and you saw
a clear view four times once i saw it
four times okay i still don't know that
i still don't know that grabbing his
wrist kept him from catching the ball
you're still done
that's absolutely insane you're just
being stubborn mike florio and your
first take was you weren't sure and you
won't back off of it and you know that
was past interference and you can't you
can't argue all the things you just
argued about the chiefs bengals game and
then say you're not sure about that one
when a guy held on to it for more than
one count more than two count and he
couldn't get his hand up there so don't
you know that was pi
maybe i'm starting to understand why
antonio brown refuses to change helmets
[Laughter]
i just still think that it needs to be
before you're going to involve replay
review for a subjective call it needs to
be
very clear and there need to be some
that we may say hey you know what it
looked like interference but it's got to
be an obvious interference like byron
pringle pushing the guy's head like
byron pringle getting blown up by the
bengals defensive back so well again
throw the red flag more here's my point
yeah coaches throw the red flag on every
pass interference call or non-call one
of the two coaches whoever got screwed
throw the red flag let's work this out
let's have more examples that we can
discuss we can flesh it out and
understand how this is going to work
going forward all right in washington
the quarterback competition is going to
work like this after the third preseason
game that's when jay gruden is going to
make his decision you know ideally you
like to have the decision made before
the third preseason game because that's
the dress rehearsal chris where do you
think this one's going to go i i feel
like it's going to be case keenum's job
ultimately you know colt mccoy just feel
like he's getting into this race too
late you know too little too late at
this point and it's probably why you
know you made the point there it's odd
that they're gonna say that after
preseason game number three but maybe
they're just trying to give colt mccoy a
little extra time or one more game of
evidence to make sure they right make
the right decision dwayne haskins i
think clearly is the most physically
talented of the group but he's raw and
we saw some of that rawness in the game
uh the other night against the cleveland
browns i feel like it's case kanam's job
to lose at this point and really would
be shocked i think if he wasn't the
starter come week one
yeah i think it's his to lose and the
reality is he will lose it at some point
i mean this strikes me as one of those
quarterback competitions where the guy
who wins the job wins the privilege to
be the first guy benched because unless
case keenum comes out and plays like he
did in 2017 and everything clicks right
at some point they're going to be
struggling at some point they're going
to need a boost by week whenever it may
be for washington something like that
there's going to be a time to say it's
time for dwayne haskins and and why rush
him into it we saw a lot of rawness from
dwayne haskins there's good there
there's bad there why thrust him into
the mix prematurely now the other side
of the coin jay gruden wants to win
football game yeah that's right and
you know maybe he goes with with the guy
that that he thinks is gonna help him
win even if it's called mccoy let's try
to win let's get hot and if it means
dwayne haskins is on the bench all year
long so be it but i i think you're right
the longer this goes the more likely
it's going to be
case keenum as the week one starter and
then we see whether or not he can hold
the job all right tom brady did his
first interview on weei of the season
it's now the greg hill show on weei tom
brady on every monday morning he was
asked about a variety of things one of
which was the new contract that
prohibits the patriots from using the
franchise tag in 2020 brady said those
are per he was asked how he feels about
being in a position where he's basically
going to be
a free agent next year he said those are
personal feelings there's a lot of
personal conversations i've had that
really aren't for other people's
knowledge i think what this is about is
this season dealing with this year
beyond this year whether it's signing
for five more years signing a franchise
tag not playing none of those things
need to be decided this year i think
what it was was focusing on this season
being in the right mental emotional
frame of mind to go out there and
perform at my highest level look chris
here's the thing tom brady does not want
to have a farewell tour no i firmly
believe that he doesn't want it to be
about him and i think people close to
him would say he'd be too emotional if
in the moment he knows this is my last
year and when he's emotional he's not as
effective and he's been trying that 10
more years playtime 45 whatever to never
have this year be the last year i'm
starting to think this year's the last
year and he's never going to admit it
because he doesn't want that derek jeter
style farewell tour because it makes it
too much about the player and not about
the team no yeah he doesn't want to deal
with that and he wants to keep us
focused on winning number seven that's
what he wants and of course he's got a a
general behind them and bill belichick
who's certainly not going to like sing
the swan song for him or anything like
that nor does he want to deal with any
of that either just not in the patriots
nature and that's why they're the
patriots that's why i respect brady and
belichick it's always business it's
always winning but uh you know to echo
what you said there
to me
here is another thing the contract we've
talked about oh the selling of the house
and here's some more comments that just
give you a little inkling that this year
could very easily be the last year i
mean when he continually says this year
it's about this season and right now and
this season that in itself
he's telling you right now he's just
trying to get through this year and
we'll see now he tries to hide it a
little bit whether it's signing a five
more years or assigning a franchise but
you know you're reading between the
lines right now there's a lot of things
that i think are pointing towards this
is a very real possibility this is the
last year of tom brady's career and the
contract situation i don't think
explains that more than anything because
what is it mike i mean if he does decide
he wants to retire and get away new
england's going to be on the hook for
what 13 million dollars of dead money as
we've seen that's not that's nothing for
a guy like for what tom brady's done for
his lifetime career here with the new
england patriots they're going to eat
that 13 million if he decides he doesn't
want to play heck we just saw we just
saw the the damn uh pittsburgh steelers
eat 20 million dollars for antonio brown
and gave him away so i don't think new
england have any time there i i it's all
signs are pointing the this is it for
tom brady yeah i i don't disagree with
that and at a minimum this is it in new
england the question is does he want to
keep going beyond where you go
i just i don't think he does i don't
think he does but i just did you know
throw it out there i know listen listen
here's the thing chris you got to
understand what you and i do for a
living you and i are here to make
stories more interesting not less
interesting so don't shout down what
could be one hell of a story for you and
me to be talking about next year or
really not that far away because that's
the thing the way this is all structured
we will know by the middle of march
whether or not he's playing for the
patriots in 2020 we will know that
because they're either gonna they're
gonna resign him or they're gonna move
on to somebody else when the middle of
march rolls around next year all right
last topic and before we get to this
because this gets fed into the pft pm
feed and you may be watching it online
let me give you a fair warning
if you're not interested in any sort of
political discourse
you can stop listening or watching now
and and trust me i would love to stick
to sports
sometimes politics gets yanked onto
sports and we hear all the time
reporters and players being told stick
to sports well is it fair chris to turn
that around on the owners and tell them
to stick to sports steven ross isn't
sticking to sports when he decides to
host a 100 000
up to 250 000 per person fundraiser for
the president that's not sticking to
sports but nobody ever says that he
should stick to sports no you don't
never why don't we why shouldn't they
stick this because he's rich and he's
white and that's why i mean i don't know
the way to sugarcoat it you know when
lebron james talks or something like
that yeah there's a lot of rich white
people and certain news uh channels that
they love to say it but yet they don't
ever turn it around on any anybody else
that's that way or if they're white or
rich or established like that that's
what it seems like to me it bothers me
you know it does i mean that's it's such
a uh you know i don't even know it's so
hypocritical in so many ways and yeah i
haven't heard that one time this week
now one thing has said about oh steven
ross just stick to sports stick to
sports or stick to you know what is he
real estate stick to real estate i don't
give a damn what you think about
politics steven ross stick to what you
do i don't give a damn what you think
and then you set a pitiful example for
people on your team and all these other
causes that you're trying to work out
and everything like that you know i mean
oh guys guys on the team are really
going to believe that you're for the
right cause there when you're supporting
a guy who's got very questionable
character along those kind of causes
right now so yeah i'm sorry that just
that gets me hot i don't know what else
to say i think i think there's also a
political playbook element to all of
this and and again we look we're
embracing the political reality here for
this last segment of pftot but i think
that the people who believe
like you and i believe
if someone expresses a disagreement or
behaves in a way that expresses a
different belief we don't feel compelled
to shout down at them stick to sports no
but on the other side the people who
every time the more conservative beliefs
instead of confronting the disagreement
if if they hear anything they don't want
to hear they shout you down stick to
sports
no it's a one-sided thing
maybe they're the smart ones because let
me tell you stick to sports may be a lot
more effective than trying to have a
reasoned conversation where you actually
understand the other side's point of
view and maybe adjust your thinking but
stick to sports prevents you from ever
doing it it is the equivalent of saying
i'm not listening stick to sports now
because let me tell you something chris
if you and i were espousing the views
that are emanating from the oval office
on a regular basis no one who would be
inclined to say stick to sports is going
to tell us to stick to sports no i know
agreed and you know yeah i just um i
don't even know what to say it just
looks like you know two rich quad two
rich white guys in new york st sticking
together and then you know hey i'll this
will bother me too he's trying to argue
that you know trump is a centrist really
oh he's a centrist really no mr ross
then you haven't been paying attention
to the world the last three years he's
far from a centrist at this point he's
the most far-right thing we've ever seen
at president so you know that's some bs2
and some more hypocrite and i'd be
bothered if i was on the miami dolphins
team and you know i understand why you
know uh equinox and soul cycle you know
hey yeah
i'd be thinking about leaving my uh
membership there too
the ceo of the foundation he started the
rise initiative for racial equality and
social justice and sports she came out
and said
i wish he hadn't done that by way of the
fundraiser right this this is not going
to go away and i i just look i look at
it this way it
if if
if we're supposed to stick to sports if
colin kaepernick is supposed to stick to
sports if other athletes are supposed to
stick to sports
then
then stephen ross should stick to sports
right you can't have it both ways no you
can't and if he's not going to stick to
sports and if he's going to engage in
the political discourse then the rest of
us have the right to engage in the same
discourse and express our beliefs and
we've probably done that not enough to
get in trouble but if we continue we
quite possibly will so let's call it a
day that's it for pftot chris sims on
button coming later today pft pm coming
later today and we'll be back tomorrow
with another edition pft live everybody
have a great monday see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports